apples 2020 iPad pro is now available
and while there aren't very many
differences compared to last year's
model the latest software updates
actually make it a better choice than
before compared to the 2019 iPad air the
major deciding factor is that the air
costs 500 dollars compared to 800
dollars for the iPad pro so in this
video we're going to be comparing
everything about them to see if spending
that extra three hundred dollars is
worth it and if you're considering one
of the other iPads like the regular iPad
or the iPad Mini subscribe right now
because we'll be doing a video soon
comparing all four of the current iPads
for starters the new 20/20 iPad pro
comes with 128 gigabytes of storage
compared to 64 on the air and if you're
planning on buying a 256 gig model
there's now only a 250 dollar difference
between the two so keep that in mind as
we compare them one of the major
benefits of the iPad pro is the updated
design from the square edges to the
rounded display corners and the even
bezel is all around the iPad pro simply
looks much more modern than the iPad air
and while some people still like the
touch ID home button on the air the
switch over to face ID on the pro is a
huge deal it just works so well even
unlocking while upside down because of
the home button on the air you have to
deal with the large bezels on both the
top and the bottom of the iPad however
it does still pack a headphone jack
which you don't get on the pro for some
people that's a big deal but for me it's
not because I have my air pods if
anything another big difference is that
the speaker's are much better on the
iPad pro with four speakers two on the
top and two on the bottom so you get
stereo sound while in landscape mode
which is great for gaming the air only
has two on the bottom so in landscape
mode all of the sound comes from just
the right side here's a speaker
comparison so you can hear the
differences between the two
[Music]
[Music]
yep the speakers are many times better
on the pro now the display tech is
extremely similar
there are literally only two differences
the pro is brighter and it gets
promotion technology testing the
brightness you can see the difference
but does it actually matter much in the
real world honestly not that much now
promotion on the other hand is huge in
my book it allows the screen to refresh
at up to 120 Hertz for buttery smooth
navigation and you truly can feel the
difference now what people don't mention
about promotion is that it automatically
brings down the refresh rate to match
the content you're viewing to help save
battery life so let's say you're
watching a video that's shot at 24 fps
like this one the pro will run at 24
Hertz while the air runs at 60 Hertz
wasting batter life without giving any
visible benefit at all another benefit
of pro motion is reduced Apple pencil
lag and as you can see in the slo-mo
clip drawing on the pro is almost
instant and it's a difference you can
feel speaking of the pencil the pro
supports the new one which is better in
basically every way especially in the
way it magnetically connects to the side
instantly pairs and wirelessly charges
the matte design feels better in the
hand and it's got a new DoubleTap to
switch tools feature which is incredibly
useful now before we get into the
performance comparison let's compare
something that not everyone will care
about the cameras the 20/20 programmer
above which I think looks so much better
design wise compared to the tiny little
camera on the air the pro actually gets
two cameras the main 12 megapixel
shooter and attend megapixel ultra wide
camera and that big gray circle on the
side is the lidar scanner which I'll get
into in a moment the air simply has an
eight megapixel main camera so here are
some photos comparing them and as you
can see the pro gives you much better
photos especially in detail and dynamic
range and of course the new ultra wide
camera gives you a really cool
perspective that you simply can't get on
the iPad air and the best part of all is
that you can shoot 4k 60fps video with
either of the pro s cameras compared to
only 1080
p 30fps video with the air now for the
front-facing selfie cam
they're both seven megapixels but since
the iPad pro has face ID
you also get portrait mode so the
selfies look much more appealing Apple
also updated the microphones on the
20/20 Pro so here's a comparison between
the two this is a microphone quality
tests on the 2019 iPad air this is a
microphone quality test on the 2020 iPad
pro now moving on to the new lidar
scanner on the pro it basically improves
depth sensing and tracking and work
similarly to how face ID does here's a
clip from AI fondo showing the lidar
scanner in action it projects a ton of
dots and then scans them to detect depth
we tested out an augmented reality app
on both of these iPads and you can
clearly see that the iPad pro is giving
us much more accurate depth and distance
tracking compared to the air which
doesn't have the lidar scanner now this
feature isn't a very big deal right now
but if you're planning on keeping your
iPad for a couple of years keep this in
mind since augmented reality apps could
become extremely popular a huge plus for
the iPad pro is that it's the only iPad
that features Wi-Fi 6 compared to slower
Wi-Fi 5 on the air now getting into
performance the pro gets the new a 12 z
chip which has a slight improvement over
the a 12 X while the air gets the
regular a 12 chip one major difference
is that the pro now gets six gigabytes
of RAM compared to only three on the air
so multitasking and using productivity
apps is going to be better on the pro
and geek bench 5 the pro scored a much
higher score in terms of multi-core
performance and in the metal graphics
test the pro scored over twice as high
as the air which is useful for things
like gaming rendering and augmented
reality the more realistic antutu test
also shows us a pretty good improvement
for the pro especially in terms of the
RAM performance the great thing about
being in 2020 is that a lot of apps have
been optimized to take advantage of the
iPad pros
formants for example you can now play
fortnight at 120fps on the iPad pro
compared to only 60 fps on the air and
there are a whole lot more games that
support 120 fps so gamers should
definitely go for the pro and even in
basic navigation the pro is gonna feel
more snappy because of the combination
of extra performance double the RAM and
the 120 Hertz refresh rate display that
makes everything feel super smooth
especially using the Apple pencil and
the quad speaker setup is also a
difference you'll feel every day
maybe even more so than promotion now
does this mean that the iPad air is bad
or that it's slow absolutely not
it's still one of the best tablets out
there and it easily beats a lot of
Android tablets but the pro is just a
big step above one huge benefit for the
iPad pro is that it's the only iPad that
supports Apple's upcoming magic keyboard
case which is going to be released in
May and it's extremely unique since it
makes the iPad float it packs the
awesome new magic Keys directly from the
16 inch macbook pro and it also features
a trackpad this is going to be great to
use with iPad OS 13.4 s new cursors
support which basically allows the iPad
to finally be a laptop replacement now
if you're interested in how to use
cursive support check out that video
after this one's over
now a big plus for the new air is that
there are going to be keyboard cases
with track pads coming soon like the
Logitech combo touch which is already on
Apple's website and yes it also features
a trackpad and it's only a hundred and
fifty dollars compared to the Apple
magic keyboard case which is three
hundred dollars but the magic keyboard
case has one more huge advantage
pass-through charging this means that
you can charge your iPad through the USB
C port on the keyboard case itself which
leaves the original USB C port free to
use for things like transferring files
or connecting to a display the iPad air
gets a lightning port that can't do that
and it doesn't supply as much power so
it's not as easy to transfer files from
a variety of devices and honestly I
think the magic keyboard case will be a
huge hit even at the $300 price because
of the brand new floating iPad design so
with all of that said and
paired which iPad is the better value
well it really depends on what you want
to do with it if you just want an iPad
for regular tasks like browsing the web
using common apps and streaming Netflix
then the iPad air is one of the best
tablets you can buy but if you want to
play games the pro is a much better
option if you want great multitasking
performance or you want to do some video
or photo editing get the pro if you want
the best Apple pencil experience and
performance get the pro if you want the
snappiest and most fluid display the pro
gets a 120 Hertz display if you really
care about how the speaker sound then
definitely get the pro if you'd like to
transfer and store files on the iPad the
pro will be much more convenient and if
you want to use the best keyboard case
ever made then you have to get the pro
but if all of those things aren't that
big of a deal to you and you'd much
rather save your cash then I'm sure
you'll be very satisfied with the iPad
air since it packs enough performance to
take care of most of the common tasks
that people need it to do so hopefully
you guys enjoy this comparison video
make sure to tap the like button and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]